يبدو أن سعر 100 دولار للبرميل محتمل في هذه المرحلة،
حيث أننا نتجه بشكل جيد، فنحن لا
نتوقع الأسعار في أوبك كما تعلم،
يمكنني أن أخبرك أن العوامل التي قد
تؤدي إلى هذا الرقم الذي ذكرته
كانت موجودة منذ بعض الوقت.  وما زال
انخفاض الاستثمار أبرز
ما رأيناه في النفط، حيث يعد انخفاض
الاستثمار في صناعة النفط أمرًا
خطيرًا وأعتقد أنه من الأهمية بمكان أن
يفهم العالم هذا الأمر بشكل صحيح،
حيث أننا من خلال انخفاض الاستثمار
نعرض بالفعل أمن الطاقة في العالم للخطر.
سيتطلب ما لا يقل عن 12
تريليون دولار من الاستثمارات العالمية
لصناعة النفط من الآن وحتى
عام 2045. هناك
احتمالات جدية بأن الأسعار ستزداد تقلبًا
مع نمو الطلب، كما تعلمون أننا نتحدث
عن عدد سكان العالم خلال العام
المقبل  بعد ستة وسبع سنوات بحلول عام 2030،
سينتقل أكثر من نصف مليار شخص إلى
المدن على مستوى العالم، ولا توجد طريقة على وجه الأرض
يمكننا من خلالها تلبية هذا المطلب للطلب على
الطاقة في المستقبل من خلال الاعتماد على
مصادر الطاقة المتجددة وحدها،
ويتوقع الشباب زيادة كبيرة في
الطلب على النفط حتى عام 2045 و  ومع ذلك، فإن
الحاجة إلى مليارات الدولارات،
نتحدث عن 600 مليار دولار
سنويًا من الاستثمارات الجديدة في
الصناعة لتلبية الطلب المتوقع،
كيف يمكنك التوفيق بين ذلك
وتوقعات وكالة الطاقة الدولية
بأن
الطلب على النفط يبلغ ذروته و  سوف
ينخفض ​​بشكل كبير بحلول عام 2030. حسنًا،
هذا سؤال رائع، وأعتقد أن هذا
السؤال يجب أن يُطرح على الوكالة الدولية للطاقة الذرية
نفسها التي تقول إنه في أقل
من سبع أو ست سنوات،
يمكن أن ينخفض ​​الطلب على النفط بنسبة تصل إلى 25 أو 30
بالمائة إذا  لست مخطئا،
اسمحوا لي أن أجيب على ذلك بهذه الطريقة بالقول إنه
قبل 30 عاما
كان استهلاك الوقود الأحفوري 80 في المائة على
مستوى العالم. وبعد
30 عاما اليوم، لا يزال 80 أو أكثر من
80 في المائة،
لذا سنأتي ونتوقع ذلك في غضون خمس أو
ست سنوات مع كل التحديات
القائمة.  في مواجهة إدخال
السيارات الكهربائية وتغلغل المركبات الكهربائية على مستوى العالم، فإن
توفر المعادن المهمة على
مستوى العالم والقضايا الجيوسياسية التي تواجهها
سلسلة التوريد اللوجستية، هو الحجم الكبير
وحجم الكهرباء المطلوبة
عالميًا لتكون قادرًا على الانتقال إلى
عالم كهربائي، فهو تحدٍ هائل
دعنا نتحدث عما
يبدو تحول الطاقة بالنسبة لأعضاء Opex
والدور
الذي ستلعبه هذه البلدان، كيف يبدو
هذا الاستثمار فيما يتعلق
بالطاقة النظيفة، علينا ضمان
النمو الذي يتعين علينا
التأكد من أن العالم لديه
ما يكفي من الطاقة المستقرة وبأسعار معقولة،
ومصادر متقطعة وموثوقة للطاقة  الطاقة
وهذا ما كان العالم يعتمد عليه طوال
هذه السنوات،
الحد من الانبعاثات، الحد من
انبعاثات الغازات الدفيئة، الحد من إحراق غاز
الميثان، خفض انبعاثات الميثان، وهذا
شيء مهم حقًا بالنسبة
لنا أن نرى منتجي النفط
يحولون أقوالهم إلى أفعال حقيقية،
وهو ما يقلقك أكثر  حول
أساسيات السوق التي تراها
أشهرًا بعد أشهر
في الوقت الحاضر، ما الذي يتغير، وما الذي
يقلقك أكثر، أود أن أقول إن هذا
قد يبقيني مستيقظًا في بعض الأحيان في
الليل،
الكلمة الأساسية
تحت الاستثمار
وأقول إذا كنا قلقين بشأن التقلبات
اليوم
فأنا لا أفعل ذلك.  لا أعرف كيف سيكون الأمر
في المستقبل